this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah thanks Tom for inviting me um you
know I have had a lot of conversation
with Tom over the last several years
actually as a practitioner landscape
architect looking for for research
advice on how to set up this design
experiment this research experiment with
in New York City and so we've had you
know he's been incredibly valuable in
that project and reading the website for
the horticulture program at Cornell I
realized that actually it's part of your
mission is this kind of agenda to
coordinate and communicate with various
publics and to kind of spread knowledge
and information that really appreciate
that that kind of perspective and not
approve the the the agenda of the the
kind of combination of academic and
applied which is what I've been trying
to do myself so I run the urban ecology
and design lab which is recent formation
about 2010 where we focus on studying
and reshaping human settlements through
research and design with the goal of
advancing urban sustainability and
resilience and I emphasize this
combination of studying and shaping
because that's essentially the
interdisciplinary approach that I try to
bring to projects is a kind of
combination of ecological research to
help quantify different particularly
ecological systems particularly the
novel ecosystems were creating in urban
environments but also recognizing that
these systems aren't necessarily
functioning in any kind of optimized way
how can we shape them as a designer so
my lab focuses on constructed ecosystems
and what do I mean by that construction
ecosystems or ecosystems that are
engineered by human actions they could
be intentional or unintentional and
they're often promoted as valuable but
their ecosystem functions and values
have not really been that well assessed
or evaluated over time there's some
interesting examples like Michael the
involvement Berg's
General Mills project I don't know has
anyone seen this project before it's
actually it was part of the corporate
landscape at General Mills in the
Midwest and it was a prairie constructed
artificial prairie landscape that
actually was surrounded by birch trees
just kind of a strange twist on the idea
of fire burning although I guess if you
turned birch inside out you can
it's fire resistant but anyway the the
the General Mills corporate office liked
it for a little while but eventually it
kind of got old and they removed it so
it was that it wasn't working very well
during the burn events when you had guys
in business suits coming in for
corporate meetings it's just sort of a
the aesthetic didn't carryover although
in our minds I think the aesthetic of a
burned Prairie is something magical so
constructed ecosystems it's also
building on you know the recognition
that the terrestrial ecosystems are
largely constructed you know and there's
a whole wave of kind of refocusing our
attention on what we mean by ecosystems
today domesticated nature driver or the
the idea of futuristic restoration
projects and including them the field of
restoration ecology which i think is
grappling with the ideas of historic
reference landscapes as a guide for
reconstructing ecosystems versus
targeted versus target ecosystems and I
think you know this this is sort of
where I'm trying to build my own
practice as a designer or ecologist so
you know you have examples like Turkey
Point in Florida where you know highly
artificial ecosystem or are highly
artificial landscape that was
constructed really as a cooling system
for heated water from the plant ends up
supporting 25% of the adult population
of crocodiles in the in the US so you've
got this kind of sort of you know
happenstance opportunities like that are
there ways in which we can start to
construct the ecosystems combining them
with infrastructure thinking about the
resources that were producing in urban
environments to promote those systems
part of this is really you know part of
this is is it has to do with human
perception in the way that we conceive
of nature and the way that we conceive
of ecosystem functions and the kind of
tools and methodologies we have to
either quantify or interpret those
ecosystem functions so I find that a
certain amount of my time is spent
negotiating with stakeholders and
working on compromise and sort of
win-win solutions as a way of developing
ecological strategies within an urban
context so I printplace a lot a lot of
emphasis on implementation also
so these are a set of bios wells that
we're constructing in Bridgeport that
was constructed in Bridgeport and in
general my my approach in part is you
know it's publication but also
publication in the real world where
you're where you're building systems
that are part of the urban environment
and evaluating the performance over time
so you know we all know when you think
about urban systems that that they're
compromised and that they're young and
novel systems and that and that there's
global environmental changes that are
taking place that are impacting those
systems in a fun in fundamental ways and
we're all we also understand that
there's you know the our understanding
of those systems is somewhat limited so
we understand that some parts of these
systems would not necessarily the
interaction between the parts and we're
making choices on incomplete information
and we're making choices at scales that
may or may not be relevant to people or
to or to ecological function or making
those linked so ultimately there's a
kind of an issue in terms of recognizing
the the novelty of urban systems and the
challenges or the shortcomings of
research practices and how do we bridge
those together how do we deal with that
kind of dilemma in current society so so
- you know there's I've heard a number
of sort of interest in this area for
example ESA has the student group is now
calling or house it has what they call
action science or action ecology where
there's a kind of proactive stance or
proactive agenda to the ecological
practices this kind of can conflict with
ideas of advocacy or the role of
objectivity in the sciences and kind of
how that how that manifests within sort
of a practice oriented science but I
sort of um I'm trying my best to bypass
or to incorporate some of those issues
into my own work so I you know I call
this area I'm calling this kind of
ecological urban design I'm still sort
of piecing together what the right
terminology might be but essentially
it's a combination of design and ecology
is it's a role for practitioner
scientists who is from in my case a
landscape architect and ecologists but
obviously you can have a variety of
combinations of interdisciplinary
practices in order to start to
investigate this area of
and I'm basically combining urban design
oops
urban urban design with ecological
engineering at some level to develop
constructed ecosystems and I really
concentrate on parks and parkland
networks land development and habitat
and urban forests stormwater hydrology
so a little bit of a jack-of-all-trades
but part of this my approach is through
collaboration with multiple parties okay
so you know the I think within these
constructed ecosystems there is you know
if you talk to any scientist dealing
with urban ecology they're gonna make
the argument that we really need to
experiment and to evaluate in to start
to develop a set of vocabulary and and
and data and information that lets us
understand what we're talking about with
urban ecosystems what's the kind what's
the theoretical framework in which were
anticipating they're analyzing urban
systems there's a lot of discussion
early on about shifting from ecology in
the city to ecology of the city where
there was you know identifying plants
and animals in urban environments and
starting to think of human social
ecological factors as constructs of
urban systems and so you know that I
think we're still it's it's still new
and developing and the urban ecological
theory is not really evolved and - or
manifest it in a way that everyone's
comfortable so it's a kind of field in
flux but but I I too am very much
aligned with this agenda of establishing
research as a goal or as a first step to
understand systems that were working on
so I developed I write published an
article assessed or ticket in 2005
called design experiments looking at new
approaches to studying urban ecosystems
where you basically develop you kind of
bridge or meld analysis with
implementation so you bridge applied
management academic science and you it
facilitates situating research in
multiple locations and urban
environments it allows you to
incorporate an education component
because you're essentially creating a
public research experiment and you know
navigates the complex public process and
government agencies which I would say
the experiment itself may or may not but
I think the combination of design and
ecology allows you to move back and
forth and negotiate opportunities with
government agencies etc it allows you to
start to in start to incorporate
research as a component of
infrastructure in urban environments
which is the essential step and gives a
public identity and negotiates sort of
public space values versus ecosystem
services so it takes advantage of
ecologists who are already studying
complex systems and are already involved
in trying to interpret you know multi
multiple variables multiple you know
complex analysis on species interactions
etc so ecologists have already been sort
of banging their head against trying to
decipher and interpret ecosystem
functions in non urban systems so here's
an opportunity to take advantage of
ecological methods ecological theory and
to start thinking about what it means
for urban design urban urban ecosystems
etc and designers in my mind or agents
of change and agents I think is an
important term here because they are can
help ecologists in situating research
experiments in an urban context and
weaving research experiments into public
or into decision making or into public
institutions like parkland does all show
you okay so you know I have sort of
three focus areas of my own and to which
I'm going to really talk about today
green infrastructure ecological planning
and in wildlife habitat actually so I'll
just mention on the wildlife habitat
side just for kind of to give you a
context that my PhD research actually
was looking at suburbanization and
amphibian populations with a large-scale
land development forty miles north of
New York City
so actually basically was working as a
master planner on a master planning team
with EDA with that related company in
New York and they were developing a
twelve hundred acre about a five hundred
hectare site at forty miles north that
had a lot of Infineon populations a lot
of breeding populations on site and you
know they wanted to develop in the
breeding the amphibians were in the way
essentially which is the typical story
of a large
development project and so I sold the
developer on the idea that we could
incorporate research and migration
patterns and look at amphibian migration
as a way of actually increasing the
opportunity for housing so we actually
made the developer money in our first
analysis somewhere around seven million
dollars worth of housing property
because essentially the vernal pool
system that was surrounded by loop road
and was you know we devastated because
this is the watershed as you can see so
it was not only migration corridors but
watershed impacts etc the what happened
was the Planning Board the environment
consultant hired by the Planning Board
identified this as a problematic issue
and really was it was raised as an
obstacle to kind of slow down the
development and the developer wanted to
make sure he got the 24 houses that were
there and so he he was looking for any
option so the idea was well let's do a
migration study look at where the
migrating patterns are and since
amphibians are fairly predictable in
terms of their migration paths we could
realign housing and have these kind of
migration corridors almost like teeth in
the location of the houses and what
happened was we did the migration 65%
we're coming from this angle and so the
developer immediately thought of the
idea of shifting housing either side
which ended up preserving the the
watershed as well and maintaining
migration corridors and getting 16
houses out of 24 so he was so excited
about it did he actually let me do the
same research across the entire property
to inform the overall master plan and so
we ended up this was the first site that
we studied and the migration patterns we
ended up setting up the same kind of
research and analysis and reorganizing
the development which is shown here in
this kind of array getting rid of one of
the major roads moving neighborhoods
around of course the typical the develop
developer you know they have a pro-forma
with a certain number of houses that
they're trying to get into a site so as
you push in one area then it pops up in
another area which is exactly what
happened here as well so there's kind of
a this relationship between academic
research and develop land development is
an interesting one because of course the
developer took advantage or used the
empirical data that was coming out of
the analysis toward to his advantage to
negotiate housing and
to push past some of the time
constraints of some of the time
constraints that are typical of a
permitting process we in the second
stage we we actually did a larval
density study looking at variation in
habitat quality across ponds and we
noted that the typical and habitat
assessment approaches with vernal pool
systems are looking at species
populations species richness that's kind
of a prioritized component but what I
found was when I'm in setting up a
research experiment where I put
amphibian populations where stocked and
ferry populations in each pond with 0 8
16 and 24 to look at whether density was
more have more of an impact versus over
habitat variation I found that habitat
variation explained a lot more of the
survival and growth rate of the
amphibians above population density
which starts to suggest or at least
opens the questions about whether
current habitat assessment practices are
effective or not and whether they need
to prioritize wetland habitats more than
species population density so we ended
up finding on the study also in the
process the least shrew because we were
wrapping fences with them you know we're
wrapping ponds with drift fences which
meant that you basically caught
everything that moved in and out and so
we had these incidentals one of them was
the least true which turned out to be a
species an endangered species which
raised other issues for the developer so
it was a very funny back and forth that
happened where the lost a lawsuit will
went out on the developer from the from
the town to address this issue of
species that weren't identified during
the EIS report so and then basically
from that I developed a series of scales
of importance that land developers are
sorry that master planners currently are
not necessarily incorporating into their
process of design and development you
know the meta population is simply not
interpreted at all except you might
argue that some of the habitat corridors
developed or are towards that intention
but there's really very little attention
to watersheds which are kind of a
fundamental part of amphibian breeding
needs migration corridors you know the
ponds in New York have zero
in New Jersey a 100-foot buffer but
amphibians travel as much as a thousand
feet so we're there's a discrepancy
between these as well okay so that this
approach you know the the approach that
I was using in my PhD was really focused
on on marrying science and and research
practices with master plan last master
planning which is a particular side of
this approach and it has more to do with
conservation I think then that and then
kind of the proactive constructed
ecosystem approach that I introduced at
the beginning but I want to return now
to this idea of constructed ecosystems
and look at particularly at restoration
ecologists who who I see is one of
several sub disciplines that are
actually grappling with what it means to
reinterpret their theory and basis of
practice in the 21st century you know so
there's part of this is that restoration
ecologists are now working more and more
with designers to develop Park systems
that are functional or have some kind of
ecosystem components to them so in this
case originally Steven Hendel from
Rutgers was working with Michael Van
Valkenburgh Sophos on the Brooklyn
Bridge project
more recently great ecology and there
you know there's ideas about wetland
construction that are taking place there
it's highly constrained as you can
imagine and so the the benefits that you
get for the costs are kind of not you
can't really do that analysis very
easily for such an urbanized park
there's also great Park in Orange County
in California that Penndel is working on
as well and where there's basically an
effort to marry or to program parkland
for ecological benefit and then the
issue becomes well how do you how do you
incorporate human use patterns into this
ecologically structured park system so
that's one of the dilemmas I think
within the restoration field so it's you
know there's a unique heritage within
restoration ecology it's an intentional
activity that initiates or accelerates
the recovery of an ecosystem with
respect to its health integrity and
sustainability attempts to return an
ecosystem to its historic trajectory
based on reference ecosystems and it
relies on careful and systematic
planning and monitoring approaches with
establish goals and performance
towards ecosystem recovery and there's
this opportunity for restoration and
applied ecology where we're
practitioners are trying or looking to
expand their territories essentially and
this has to do with the number of
factors that we're facing today
including invasive species or you know
coastal resilience and global warming
etc so I see it is uniquely placed but I
also think it provides a it starts to
expose some of the issues that we face
and how to marry the or how to rethink
our approach you know the there there
Restoration comedy builds on on things
like agriculture where you're dealing
with production and optimization
practices so there's a whole working
component to restoration ecology that
has relevance within an urban context it
also where there is incomplete knowledge
and there's the necessary necessity to
make decisions on incomplete knowledge
which i think is one of the differences
between a lot of the applied ecologists
and the basic science approaches so it's
expanding into these new applications
adaption adaptation methods efforts to
quantify yuka system services ways of
controlling invasive species thinking
about natural landscaping to substitute
for lawns or habitats and public park
amenities you know and they're working
on land types that are fundamentally
urban and that have that really need to
be re-evaluated and reconstructed for
future promotion of ecosystem services
and urban environments they're dealing
with abandoned sites brownfields
wetlands etc but you know there's
questions about what to prioritize and
how important are people in this system
you know when you're fall if you're
following the money how do you or you do
you follow the money or do you follow
the the best ecological benefits in
terms of prioritization and how do you
assess the long-term resilience and
sustainability and then there's this
other aspect of the aesthetic form I
think which is an important component of
restoration ecology that I'll mention in
a second but um and then finally this
idea of defining ecosystem function how
do you define these systems with an
urban type organized concept constant
construct so you know historically
restoration ecologists have tended
towards naturalistic design strategies
so even though I wouldn't say I would
say that most restoration ecologist
probably would not say
they have a design ideology there's a
default design ideology which is
essentially naturalistic may construct a
system to make it look like nature you
know and also hopefully construct the
system to make it function like nature
but looking like nature doesn't
necessarily mean functioning like nature
so in looking like nature it also has
some problems with it for example and
this is something that joy zedler has
mentioned you know when you construct
these systems that look natural and you
go through the the pains of kind of
organizing in organic forms it's often
can be from a construction standpoint
more costly also you um it's hard to
compare those systems to other systems
that you create so you're not actually
you're actually losing an opportunity to
embed research components and modularity
into the system that you can evaluate
over time and test and evaluate
performance so you're you're you you end
up spending all fair amount of money
constructing a system that's essentially
a one-off and that you can evaluate as a
whole the other issue in my mind at
least is that you know funding
opportunities trying to get funding to
construct these kinds of things often
the funder is looking for something that
it can be identified and when you have a
restoration site next to an adjacent
Natural Area and they look almost the
same it becomes kind of difficult for um
you know to get money or solicit funding
in an urbanized world where you're you
know you want it to have some identity
or meaning so on top of that I think
many restoration ecologists remain
dedicated to their traditional practices
which is understandable because you know
in a way the notion identifying a
historic reference is sort of a it's a
way forward it's a way to have to
validate decision making and if you
don't have that approach and you're
thinking only into the future or into
some kind of you know futuristic or
target ecosystems it's more challenging
to think to design what you prioritize
okay so as restoration ecologists expand
their breasts are rethinking the
reference ecosystems and they're more
and more working with stakeholder
communities so just an example of a
recent project that I see is being kind
of a futuristic restoration I don't have
people gone to the Museum of Modern Art
rising turns
and make it down to the the rising turn
so there was some interesting projects
there it was very fairly architectural
but um Kate ORFs project called oyster
texture was this notion of taking the
lifecycle of the oyster and mapping it
onto the harbor of New York City and
she basically the notion was essentially
to to organize the the early stage of
the organism so that it would be
essentially be play a role in cleaning
the kiwanis Canal and then to move that
system into a kind of wave attenuation
structure that would where you
essentially plant these organisms along
as a kind of buffer or wave attenuation
for New York City so there was and she
started to bridge those ideas with you
know pedestrian paths for example where
the the ecological systems would be
underneath the paths for ease of access
and started to incorporate it into the
design of the city
okay so part of this idea or this
approach to bridge ecological strategies
with design incidents that kind of build
on the restoration ecology approach has
to do with compromise and I find again
and again that I'm trying to determine
where and how to compromise and I think
that this is a struggle for the science
world because ultimately you don't you
know there's things that you can
compromise and there's things that you
can't and it's it's a tough you know
it's a challenge to decide what you give
up one of the things that I asked John
abran he was visiting Yale recently was
whether you know if he was actually
talking about this notion of compromise
and so I asked well with you is there
are there ways in which we would then
compromise the science in order to
incorporate it into for example into the
time scale of a land development project
so if a land development master planning
process takes you know nine months to a
year or maybe a year and a half you know
there's always so much research that you
can be able to do that's netting that
from a science perspective that's going
to be valuable I mean you might get one
season you might get two seasons in if
you're strategic but you know that in
other words you know the data
the results aren't going to be as useful
or add from a science perspective aren't
gonna be as helpful so but but you know
that in and we debated discuss to that
topic and his sense was that the science
is the science and the approach is you
stick by a certain methodology that's
been developed or your results are not
as useful or not as valuable and so I
think this is a real struggle I looked
into this a little bit while working at
IDO I got a client and practice grant to
to participate with Presidio Trust which
is on the west coast and if folks have
been to this pretty amazing post
military landscape right in San
Francisco it's it's um it's interesting
for a lot of reasons but there's a
number of stakeholders there there you
got the the cultural historians who
basically you know it's a historic
landmark and not only are the buildings
historically landmarked but the
landscape is historically a landmark so
for those of you that have been there
the it was one of the largest a
forestation efforts in the country from
the 1880s 1890s where they're actually
trees were planted in monoculture blocks
in regiments to mimic the military
history eucalyptus and a variety of
other species and they grew up into a
mature canopy so the whole ecosystem
this this you know scrub shrub community
coastal community is a forested
environment that a lot of people think
of as being the historic nature of that
area so there's a very complicated
stakeholder relationship to this
landscape partly historical partly the
public users who walk their dogs there
and would die to see these trees removed
you know partly the maintenance folks
and and partly the restoration folks who
actually are very keen on on removing
the forest and trying to replace it with
a biologically rich environment so we
were working with each of these
stakeholders and through dialogue
negotiating or learning about what their
drivers were what their interests were
so we dealt with public groups with
nature lovers and with historical folks
and there's a you know this is all by
the way in National Park so it became
went shifted from a military base to a
national park so it's under the National
Park Service it's the most urban or one
of the most urban national parks at this
gateway and you're
another but it's um so you've got not
only is a public the local public who
live adjacent and there's actually sixty
million square feet of real estate on
site so people actually rent property on
the historic base but there's people
living right outside and then there's
the entire United States public who you
know who has some rights to this land as
the National Park so we were working on
a particular area that is becoming their
sustainability Center and we were there
was a biologically rich sort of creek
bed here that had the generals house at
the top right here and and military
housing here by the way this is the only
community garden on the entire property
there's a list of hundreds and hundreds
of people that want to have a community
garden on that on the Presidio and the
but the historic stakeholders have
fought them off for years so that
there's their what the restoration
ecologists are that's re the community
gardeners then went into the map library
and look through old maps and found that
there had been a a Victory Garden on
this particular property on this area
and so they got their gardening their
community garden it's like a one acre
piece out of about twelve hundred acres
so you know this was a pretty
interesting site because it had been
designed as a public garden so it was a
historical garden its associated with
the generals house but it also had been
left alone for quite a while and so it
had grown and was and and the the
community developed restoration ecology
group had a greenhouse system here and
had been pretty actively restoring this
creek bed system so there's a lot of
involvement here by the one last point
was that the same group that had worked
here had worked on Inspiration Point
which is right around there and
basically Inspiration Point is the
highest point in Presidio and it's got
ever had at one point a fantastic view
of the whole Bay but the trees had grown
up and blocked the entire view so you
couldn't see anything so the Presidio
trusts coordinated with the local
restoration ecologists and developed a
community-driven restoration project
there where Presidio thrusts came out at
night and cut down the trees removed
them and had them that right away in the
morning after everyone was out planting
locally gathered seed seed plants from
local genotypes so it was this kind of a
political strategy using logical
restoration at folks as it kind of means
to negotiate and of course the views
fantastic now and everyone's happy about
it but it's hard to get past that first
wave so we found in our analysis that
essentially there wasn't one solution to
this strategy it was too small to really
have your cake and eat it too and we
came up with this idea that this bridge
that actually really just became a kind
of an illustration of the compromises
that were that one might make with a
site like this essentially you could
have wildlife habitat and no human
access where you could view over the
system or maybe you have a bridge that
crosses it so you have controlled access
and wildlife viewing or you could have
complete access and make it into a park
system so it becomes more of an
integrated Park but then your ecological
benefits aside from water quality and
impacts that are highly reduced so you
know what we found from this was that
you you ended up with a bunch of
questions you know what's more valuable
in an urban park setting is it public
access or habitat preservation what
takes precedent in the historic national
park ecosystem function or historic
preservation you know can public use and
recreation be integrated with habitat
enhancement and control of visitation
and how can one ensure that opposing
stakeholders reach a winning consensus
rather than everyone giving up too much
which in some ways is what we found
through this process is that no one was
really willing to give up their
perspective easily okay so I've talked a
little bit about design experiments and
this strategy that I've been putting
forward in terms of coupling ecological
research and urban design as a means to
move forward and part of the argument is
here you know traditional research
approaches you set up you know ecologist
are looking to study this system to
understand how it works so you set up a
experimentation you analyze the system
and from your results you have it you
can get ideas as a kind of adaptive
management for example to alter the
system and as a kind of feedback with
design experiments you're sort of taking
for granted you're assuming that this
is not necessarily working all that well
or you're working with a constructed
system where you can manipulate the
system and and put in a kind of new
functioning system that you can then
analyze over time so it's a kind of
proactive approach that brings in the
science and research strategy but it
brings it in in the process of change so
at the same time experimentation is it
has an interesting aesthetic there is
you know spatial sort of modularity to
the experimentation there's a kind of
geometry driven by statistical means or
statistical needs but it actually has a
relation to kind of a design aesthetic
or design practices so I'm going to talk
about that in a second but I wanted to
give you an example of a design
experiment that I proposed for the High
Line where basically it's a prairie
ecosystem highly constructed prairie
ecosystem on porous paving and you
basically use a fire-retardant material
periodically and you'd burn a strip and
then that would become your path and
then you know two or three years down
the line you'd burn another strip and
then that would become your path and
then there would be a self-seeding
prairie kind of landscape for education
purposes for example at the same time
design experiments have this stakeholder
outreach or stakeholder engagement
component to it it's in the public realm
it's a research driven but it's also
implementation based and through this
kind of implementation practice such as
projects that I worked on in Harlem on
the community garden 123rd Street it's a
way of getting people involved and you
start to you know people come out of the
woodwork or start to participate in land
development especially in an urbanized
context and then finally it's really the
intention is also to generate and
develop urban ecology as a science and
to start to think about ways such as
Larry Baker's work on household scale
ecosystem dynamics to think about scales
of analysis that are appropriate or that
are meaningful to decision-makers
policymakers and were homeowners okay so
I've mentioned this idea of the
aesthetics of experimentation and
actually and so I wanted to just go
through and show you a few examples of
what I'm thinking about here
so you know there's Tillman's work you
know these kind of music azam ideas
Hubbard Brook this is a million trees
project I'm gonna show you know there's
going back to the idea of the concern
that I raised about restoration
ecologists and how there's a default
naturalistic design intent behind the
approach for a designer going through
for example my experience at Harvard
everyone is hypersensitive to what your
your design influences are it's a it's a
hypersensitivity and actually for
landscape architects in the United
States one of the biggest challenges is
how to get out of the underneath the
shadow of Olmstead who has created this
incredible shadow partly because of his
mamaia projects and the the breadth of
his projects but you know he brought in
this whole notion of the picturesque
from the English which really evolved
out of a rural agrarian landscape
quality that ended up that went through
the painting it made its way to the
landscape design and and then when it
was brought to the States my
interpretation is that it kind of
coagulated or sort of gelled with the
wilderness ethic or the wilderness
concept and you know people have talked
about the idea that Yellowstone was
probably selected because it had been
cleared periodically through burning
practices and reminded people of the
idealic nature so you know as a
landscape architect this this is
actually a pretty big challenge you know
am i do I design naturalistically or not
is you know it's a sort of branch in the
in the field and a lot of landscape
architect's struggle with the redefining
an aesthetic while often being pegged as
or being requested to do naturalistic
design because not only is it a dilemma
in the field of landscape architecture
it's a it's a perception or an idea held
by Americans at large because all sense
Park systems and others afterwards
essentially introduce the picturesque
across the country so everyone when you
think about a park for most people you
think about a park you think of a
picturesque style or naturalistic Park
it's very different in Europe where
there's a lot of geometry as a component
so design experiments bypass that
ideology dialogical layer
get ecologists and designers negotiating
and working around statistical drivers
and geometry and modularity as a medium
through which you can come up with
design aesthetic this is Robert
Smithson's project where he called an on
site where he would take material from
sites organize it in some sort of a
frame and then bring it off-site and
have these kind of like the six
materials of his site would all be in
these kind of containers he was very
interested in in what material meant
when it was removed from an area or were
given a kind of structure you know
there's Allen Sanborn topographic
projections where there is a kind of
effort to create modularity around an
organic form you know in the structures
to frame that there's also a whole
investigation into dynamic systems and
dynamic patterns and how to represent
those or how to represent multifaceted
perspectives so this idea of dynamic
ecosystems has relevance in the art
world it's a question partly of
determining how to bridge the the
dialogue you know there's a so from that
I've kind of pushed for this idea of a
collage aesthetic which basically takes
maybe some some of Gleason's mapping of
prairie ecosystems and in the UW
Arboretum in that dynamic nature and
builds on the the data rich capacity of
designers today or the ability to kind
of crunch a lot of information with the
various programs to think about it a
design aesthetic I've always been
interested in REM cool houses project
for Downsview Park as a as a site for
researching Island biogeography and
habitat for doors it wasn't really part
of the study at all but it's it's you
know he had this notion that he would
create circles of ecosystems or circles
of landscape that would be programmed
and you know would be great to set up
some kind of a large-scale study on on
animal migration patterns or animal
movement patterns across these patches
and then there's precedent for combining
science and design going back you know
going we're going way back but I think
Mel Chen's revival field with the USDA
chemists and
one of the earliest reclamation projects
in the country funded by art money for a
kind of science project I think is a
really interesting example of this
bridging okay so I want to just now take
you into or discuss the million trees
project which I worked on first at at e
da which actually you'd all have merged
with AECOM design so it became a giant
conglomerate while I was there but
basically we sorry we won the project in
2008 with it was through EDA and donna
wall cabbage in new york Donna had a
on-call contract with the parks
department there are eight landscape
architecture firms that have on-call
contracts with the New York City Parks
Department and so any project that comes
out they've been on it and whoever is
deemed the best bidder wins the project
when this project came along it was a
very unusual project for those eight
practitioners because it really had a
underlying you know research and science
questions and and the kinds of the kinds
of issues that the Cornell horticultural
is probably the making them one of the
most adept you know or the kind of depth
that you that you show here but in the
practitioner world you know you don't
have that kind of knowledge base
thinking about how to construct an urban
forest you know and what and and so
Donna called edawn and we decided to
partner and then we created a series of
outreach efforts including my telephone
calls to Tom what LO to try to infuse
this process with research ideas and
research education so you know the I
remember sitting at a community meeting
and one of the community members asking
you know why why a million trees why not
trees and shrubs and you know why not
some a variety and the chief naturalist
said well you know when the mayor tells
you to plant a million trees you plant a
million trees and and it's it's kind of
that you know it's so this project is as
much political as it is ecologically
driven I would say maybe more political
than ecologically driven but we were
really interested in the questions about
how do you construct an urban for
you know what what are the criteria that
you need to take into consideration and
we were also really interested in the
role of analysis and research that one
might be able to do was enough
coordination upfront on you know seed
source the influence of politics and
budget on on performance the the issue
of parts maintenance practices and how
that influences designed the whole
question that New York City has been
asking about community boards and kind
of discrepancies ins in terms of
community board canopy cover and then
local questions about public parks and
urban forests about things like species
richness and the value of species
richness over how to deal with invasive
species etcetera so there are lots of
questions to ask so the project was
actually rather large it was a it's it
was a combination of citywide how to
plant you know million trees across the
city and in this case we were the
project was split between the New York
restoration project is doing
implementation on private land and
street trees and the Parks Department
doing work with with us on public park
land so we're really looking only a
public park land not at street trees
which is a fundamentally different
draught set of drivers but we looked at
dominant vegetation and pH and moisture
levels is a way of categorizing land
types and we had decided early on that
we would identify in the areas with a
lot of invasive species then we would
replace those with forests because one
of our dilemmas was if we're planting
dense forests four feet on center across
the city what's that going to do to the
state of public access and you know Park
Man and so we thought it would be
politically strong to propose replacing
invasives and there are a lot of
invasives in New York so you know we
developed a series of invasive
management strategies for the project
that we're all pretty intensive and
these were these were a kind of
combination of research ideas coupled
with the parks department natural
resources group which is a sub group
within the parks department is a very
unusual and sophisticated group of
practitioners that
have been doing this kind of work at
least at a smaller scale for about two
decades and then we came up with a
series of species palates depending on
the alkalinity alkalinity the hydrology
of the soils and we had this process of
site analysis or site density ssin which
is really a parks management practice a
fairly rapid assessment of what's what's
on the ground
oops sorry so the way that we made this
work because we started talking about
research as a component of the design
from early on from the first actually
from our response in the RFP and the
first several meetings but meeting after
meeting we would bring up this idea of
research as a component you know of the
of the process and there were you know
there was conversations like you know we
don't necessarily know what the benefits
of soil amendments are gonna be whether
whether it's gonna be more beneficial
for the plants that we planted over time
or whether it's going to actually
increase invasive species recruitment
patterns and you know we're not quite
sure what's better or you know questions
about about species richness you know
whether or not it's but it's going to be
whether or not we'll have more survival
if we plant a higher diversity of
species or less you know so there were
certain things that we were uncertain
about and the parks department was
concerned about those issues but they
had they were in this role where they
had incomplete information and it had to
make choices so we decided to frame the
research questions around the parks
management assumptions where there's
debated topics in the literature but the
parks department has to take action and
so we essentially developed a series of
research questions that this it builds
on the flow of knowledge with the sorry
the biodiversity an ecosystem
functioning literature so if this here
is a representative of the BEF
literature and basically that
information it has made its way into the
public realm through a variety of means
but let's say here you co system
services as a concept so ecosystem
services comes forward and it embodies
the
information and debated topics within
BEF literature where there are a lot of
debates about the value of species
richness etc this information then makes
its way right to the policymakers so
there's an idea that that that by
increasing canopy in an urban
environment that you're going to
increase ecological value and part of
this influence the urban forest Sciences
where the u4 model for example and other
models are used to in take information
in but you know they look at for example
they do for model doesn't incorporate
species interactions which may be one of
the fundamental aspect of how this force
is going to perform over time so there's
a number of assumptions that make their
way into the u4 model but nonetheless
that influences decision-making about
how many trees to plant and about what
the benefits of these trees are going to
provide from a green infrastructure
standpoint and a canopy standpoint for
the urban environment so policymakers
then direct the Parks Department to
plant a million trees the parks
department particularly the natural
resources group which I mentioned have
experience planting trees over the last
20 years and so they are able to take
that on as an initiative and move
forward with it as an agenda but what's
missing is or what's happening is a lot
of the assumptions here are getting
embedded in the process and so what we
were trying to do at the you know now
the Yui D lab is to link this together
again by developing the the million
trees project as a research project as a
long-term research project so these are
two sites so we not only did we do
citywide implementation but we also
identified pilot sites where we could
develop large-scale research as a
component we were worried about the slow
pace of the citywide implementation and
the variability across sites in the city
and we wanted to have a couple discrete
sites where we had a lot of replication
for research this is the old Queens fair
there's Willa Lake here tom is doing
work on Willow Lake now in this area as
you mentioned earlier and here it is
there the MTA are adjacent this is
actually a pretty interesting
hydrologically modified in urban
condition where I was in a I was talking
the parks department about the notion we
were talking about the notion of using
this as a coastal adaptation management
site because there's tide gates and in
it floods it turns out there's a this is
what I've heard that there's a putt-putt
owner just just below that is is the
obstacle to negotiating trying to
reconstruct her to use this as a coastal
adaptation just to show you some of the
local politics that can get in the way
but I'm going to talk today more about
cocina which is located here that all
the World's Fair is right there so it's
actually a pretty interesting linear
ecosystem and actually Queens Botanical
Garden is adjacent okay so this is the
site and basically it's actually one of
the largest community gardens in the or
the largest I think in New York City and
there's a hospital here at Queens
Botanical Garden east/west International
School and what we've done is we've
embedded these a series of research
plots throughout the park land and we
part of our agenda was to was part of
our goal was how do you design parkland
that can accommodate research as a
component of the design and and and and
be part of them and be something that is
bought into or accepted within the
public context and so basically the
strategy was where the research plots
were surrounding it we designed what I
call the cluster planting which was
essentially intended to modulate the
grid of the trees and then outside of
that I actually developed what I call
the picturesque style which goes back to
the earlier discussions that I was
having about whether or not my own
debate in my naturalistic designer or
not well ultimately the picturesque it
served as a kind of Trojan horse for the
research plots so the interpretation was
okay this is a picturesque style it's a
typical typical urban parkland design so
there weren't really many issues with it
it was only about two weeks before we
actually planted the trees staging was
completed we were on site trees were
there that the the parts manager and I
turned to each other and she said no
what do we mean by the picturesque
exactly and then we actually sat down
and talked about
fifteen feet on center or 25 feet you
know some sort of arrange and we also
planted la trees along pathways and
desire lines and along recreational
areas like mothballs fields to
essentially stitch to create a kind of
more mature landscape that the research
plantings which were you know small at
the time and grow into so part of this
was intentional as a design part of it
was designed as a research project and
we not manipulated so we had soil
amendment those soil amendment we had
high diversity low diversity and we also
planted an understory vegetation versus
no understory so we have seven you know
7 by 8 factorial with 56 plots and we
went through and did a series of
sampling and vegetation biomass studies
etc to develop a better baseline data
and now we're in the process of looking
at the second stage so one of the things
that we've been learning from this
design experiment which follows a model
that I'm calling build it and they will
come which is used in a variety of means
but essentially if you build a good
research project in an urban context
with a lot of replication then the idea
is will it attracts other scientists to
come and do their own research on this
site one that is the example of the
adaptive experimentation from ASU where
the scientists there identified the
circle these circles that were part of a
domestic housing military housing
project that were all similar sized and
shaped and they had the same number of
houses around them so it's an example of
a kind of identifying a research
artefact in an urban context that you
can that it has enough replication that
you can set up an experiment on it
so this is a different approach where
you embed you kind of virally embed
yourself in the design process and you
construct these research projects for
for the purpose of analysis and giving
people opportunities the downside to
this is that you you get the the funding
for the experimental design in the
experimental construction we're all
essentially paid for through public
funding and by the way the the
contractor who was fantastic was it was
a great way to build an expiry
to have a contractor and his entire crew
go out and sort of established this
whole thing but it's the second half of
the design experiment that I'm still
it's still sort of a struggle because
what you have is this constructed
experiment but you don't but the funding
is not there for the monitoring
component so then you're going out and
trying to essentially sell the project
to different agencies to fund the second
half of this experimental setup or this
experimental research so we're in that
phase now looking at questions like are
constructive Native communities and
urban landscape sustainable you know in
questioning whether they're really
whether they're resilient in the face of
a variety of urban stressors we've
identified that that you know drought is
an issue that's already taken place on
our site vandalism is pretty common as
students that are in the schools
adjacent like to break the trees and use
them as for sword-fighting you know the
there's some really interesting dynamics
for example we've spent you know two
years eradicating or trying to eradicate
mugwort
and it turns out that the Asian
population living in this area like to
spread mugwort because it's used in for
tea and for I think for sushi or other
kinds of food so it's actually this kind
of you know back and forth between you
know that's going on in urban ecology so
the project itself included a wide range
of stakeholders and and part of this is
the role of the design experiment is
bringing the agenda of stakeholder a in
alignment or as a way of furthering the
goals of stakeholder B for example so
you know the parks department was really
looking for green infrastructure and
biodiversity and habitat and they had a
capital investment component that was
going into it
meanwhile the scientists were looking
for ways of testing management
assumptions in establishing manipulative
experiments to study these systems in
the you know the parks and recreation
natural resources group are really
looking for evidence-based management
and so they're looking for a kind of
quick analysis and and invasive species
control practices so and finally the
people like the Queen's Botanical Garden
who are somewhat involved as well as in
the same
Hawthorne middle school are looking for
research and education opportunities
ways of getting students involved in the
process to understand their environments
I talked about this already a little bit
the idea of the the research plot
adjacent to the cluster and the cluster
adjacent to the picturesque and the
picturesque adjacent to the LA these are
just sort of the design drawings that
were used to to negotiate the process
and then this is an example of the plot
itself and the way we set it up and then
the the research plot itself was
originally a grid and even though the
parks department plants have planted
several hundred thousand trees in a four
foot on center grid when the when the
when we sent them the grid they were
troubled by kind of the way it looked
and so they wanted us to kind of or they
gave some push back to rethink how we
were organizing the species and what we
were what our intentions were and so we
thought more about it and in the you
know the parks department they liked to
plant in patches and and we came we
started taking on that idea and then we
came up with what we had actually called
the naturalistic plot which was
essentially an organization of trees in
patches or quadrats of similar species
and in these kind of clumps and then we
reorganized the shrubs and herbaceous on
a different alignment to sort of break
down the grid and what we actually
realized was it became a better
experimental set up because we were able
to ask questions at the micro plot scale
where we were we're now sampling in each
one of these quadrats and assessing the
function or the changes in soil
microbial community as well as tree
species performance of these local
clumped groups and able to compare in
Colombia - Colombia so it turned out to
be one of these examples of a win-win
situation which is sometimes hard to
achieve these are the plots here this is
this is the I'm working with mark
Bradford who is a soil ecologist at Yale
also and so he's really been active in
analysis of microbial community we're
also working with rich Hallett from the
US Forest Service on
chlorophyll and fluorescence to look at
as a method of assessing tree
performance and tree health over time
and we've actually found some
preliminary information at least in this
box plot indicating that there are
differences between species on site and
then we're we have this this is kind of
I wouldn't call idea collaboration but
these outreach programs with local
schoolchildren who are coming out and
we're trying to work with the parks
department and the school to come up
with research that would is doable on a
short-term and meaningful to students so
we're looking at things like cover
boards as a way of setting up a sampling
practice for local school communities to
do their analysis so you know I'm
thinking I think of this as a kind of
applied urban ecology that has a
research aesthetic and it's you know
designing an experimental landscape and
so I you know to me I think it's
starting to bridge these fields of
design and science as an approach and
you know in part of it as I mentioned
before is the role of implementation and
getting in actually building these
things so that you can start to document
all the pitfalls and the challenges of
implementation over time just what we've
been doing we one of my students
recently did a lifecycle assessment of
the project because essentially the
contractor kept notes on a weekly basis
which stacked about this high of
everything that they did from the start
and so he looked at the different stages
of the process and how that impact
ecological function from a lifecycle
assessment and found that the that the
treats the tree plantation process was
really the biggest consumer of energy
but invasive me invasive management
although you can't me see that number
for some reason it was also pretty high
it's a black one and and and so you know
we were his analysis suggested that that
basically it's going to take somewhere
between 11 to 41 years to pay back all
the energy input that went into
implementing the million trees project
at least on Cocina if that's a case
study so yeah this is one of the are we
I think being made about urban parkland
a forestation practices but what some of
the things that this doesn't take into
account are species interactions which
is a kind of important one and a whole
range of social human factors you know
that the value of having a canopy or an
urban forest in the city I've been
interested Tom and I've talked about
this before of looking at you know
because of the Asian longhorn beetle and
some of the other constraints on the
plant that our plant palette options
were limited and so we planted a lot of
Oaks and Oaks gave off volatile organic
compounds planting them adjacent to
roadways you know you could get some
mixing of exhaust with these the VOCs
and so there's basic questions about
what it is that we're doing and what the
implications of what we're doing they're
going to have over time in terms of
ecosystem services or ecosystem benefits
that really need to be evaluated but as
Tom can attest it's a kind of a
difficult effort to try to understand
the turbulent dynamics of that
environment was okay so I wanted to
briefly how am i doing on time
over then let me pull let me in there
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu